let's bring in Doug Gottlieb Fox Sports
college basketball analyst good morning
Doug thanks for joining us good morning
a chiropractor is not a doctor
a chiropractor is a very very important
person to know when you have a crick in
your neck or a rib out but they always
want to put you on a treatment plan and
they always want to do x-rays when all I
want to do is get adjusted
sorry that's yesterday driving listening
to this outstanding radio program thank
you Doug
all right now let me start with the
Sacramento Kings if I gave you over
under 40 wins for the new and improved
Sacramento Kings you're taking the over
or the under under under look I thought
they got the number one prospect in the
draft last night and I think you know
Darren Fox is a little disappointing but
you're - he should be better and they've
clearly tried to change the culture of
that place new arena is spectacular I
mean I look I I think there are brighter
times on the horizon but remember it's
27 wins when half the league tanking you
know I meant like so-so
and you had teams that were just
completely loaded up with with injuries
at the top you know the Golden State
Warriors cycle through injuries you look
at what happened with the pelicans
you're still in the West I would expect
the West to get better especially if
LeBron comes and joins the Lakers
I just 40 wins is a big big jump 27 40s
is a huge huge jump for that that team
doesn't mean they didn't do well last
night but just means we need to take a
deep breath I would take the under on
that by the way who defeated the Golden
State Warriors twice last season that
would be the Sacramento Kings absolutely
all right the biggest surprise last
night was I think - most people would be
Michael poore jr. sliding to to Denver
look he's got when the injury issues er
are there you know whether it's a back
or a hip but those are things that
really scare people off and then you
know there's just a sense of kind of
entitlement and arrogance there - which
like hey duty paid three games in
college like let's take a breath here
you know I think you know he comes from
a really good family and his dad's done
a great
job protecting him from the real world
but like you know when you're raised in
a bubble and told that you're you're
great sometimes you start believing a
little bit too much so I think him
sliding was a surprise to a lot of
people not as big a surprise in NBA
circles but but a surprise because he
was some people's number one prospect
and number two prospect in the country
coming into the year but I'm also
fascinated Doug that you have to get to
a certain point where you say that
Michael Porter is worth the risk so
maybe not worth the risk at 8 or 7 or 9
but then you get to 14 and and then he
becomes worth the risk like at what
point does a guy who has question marks
around him health-wise become worth the
risk
well I mean Denver is a perfect example
right like they have yo Kitsch is a star
man yo Kitsch is the best player in the
NBA that most non NBA fans have never
heard of so they already have a already
have a nice little roster some really
good players Gary Harris they don't they
don't have to depend upon him P flames
out at 14 like I whereas you know like
Atlanta with trae young they're gonna
build this hole they're gonna trade
their point guards they're gonna build
the whole thing around him if he fails
everybody gets fired or at least the
coach gets fired so I think it just it
depends upon where you are where you're
drafting and how much you're depending
on this player to come in and help you
I'm not sure if I'm quick like look I
love Collin Sexton I thought he was the
best point guard in the draft and I love
that Cleveland took him but I'm not sure
if I'm Cleveland I'm losing LeBron if I
went to taking a swing that's it
that's a home run swing for Michael
Porter jr. because if he's healthy you
know you know if he gets humbled a
little bit I mean he can be an all-star
whereas I don't know if Collin Sexton is
is an all-stars pose just a really
really good point guard so again I think
it's it's franchise dependent its roster
dependent and then it kind of depends
upon your GM and how confident they are
that if the pick fails or if his body
breaks down you can survive it you know
like Philadelphia there's there's a team
that could have could have taken a swing
at him considering they've taken even
with the previous regime they had taken
injured players and been willing to sit
them for a year remember if you sit him
for a year that's going to be
essentially two years without playing
basketball
that's that's not a good sign for how
his body's gonna hand out hold up in the
rigors and yet Doug Gottlieb Fox Sports
college basketball analyst joining a
Stan Patrick show what Dallas did I
I mentioned it yesterday that I wouldn't
be surprised if they were looking for
the heir apparent to Dirk Nowitzki and
they went up for Luca dumb chick are you
surprised that they got him and what
they gave up and what Atlanta did with
getting Trey young look like well
there's this - let's start with Dallas
obviously they gave up a lot but I mean
I'm most confident that he's going to be
a really good player like I don't know
if he'll be a I don't think he'll be an
all-star maybe is a one time also I had
no idea because you know like look he's
got change his body he's got to get a
little bit more athletic which he can in
the states that continue improve his
shooting but he's going to be a good NBA
player and he's able to play right away
he put her best to Dennis Smith but now
you kind of got a backcourt that you
know there's a team that was they were
trying the last couple years they try to
be good and they have injuries they
start tanking so you don't really know
what the Dallas Mavericks are how what
their ceiling actually is
did they overspend you know next year's
first-round pick probably not because I
think they know they were a lot better
than their actual record because they
tried to be bad I mean you should see
the fourth quarter roster that fourth
quarter
lineups that the Dallas Mavericks are
out there they're guys you had no I know
idea you need to go to like people are
scrambling looking through you know
their media guides when they check into
the game because Dallas was trying to be
bad so I don't think their first-round
draft picks can be terribly valuable
next year I think it's a really good
pick he solid he he won an NBA when a
groat championship and a Spanish
championship at 18 years old I don't
know how you could go wrong there
especially when you have yeah
athleticism of Dennis Smith and you
could put the two of those guys together
as for Atlanta you know you bring a GM
over and he comes from Golden State he's
trying to recreate Golden State and have
the chance of more first-round picks
next year which would you like I think
Trey Young's probably gonna win Rookie
of the Year because they don't have much
else they're gonna give him the ball
spread it out and just have him go
there's me nights gonna be right great
there's nitrogen is gonna be horrible
poor
I mean it's guys when he's just gonna
he's going to give up twice as many as
he gets but they're gonna play the
numbers game and just try and throw a
bunch of stuff at the wall you know I
like order the kids that got from
Maryland who can play a bunch of
positions but I don't think he's great
so I again I they're trying to do the
Golden State light thing and it's great
but Golden State has only worked once
we'll see if it works a second time and
you know in Atlanta Jerry West is up to
something with the Clippers what did you
make with the Clippers did I generally
liked it I'm not a huge Myles bridges
fan but I think he did Wayne okay so
who'd they get I'm trying there's so
much movement there they didn't get they
got Alexander yes I like everybody likes
Alexander the big question is can he
shoot but I mean he has if you watched
him with Kentucky like that team was
kind of a mess a lot of low basketball
like you guys and he was just kind of a
stabilizing force you know the big
question with him is Kenny shoot and
then the big question with with Jerry
West is hey can can Jerry West land a
big free agent everything needs that
touch before has turned to gold
you know from Memphis to the Lakers to
Golden State and he's Midas touch if you
can fix the Clippers now like we have to
yes immediately go sit next to God I
mean it's be remarkable but I do like I
like what they did in the trap you know
I like the most or maybe one of the two
or three I like what Chicago did Chicago
did a really nice job window Carter's
probably a starting big guy and then you
know the kid they got from from Boise
State is tremendous challengers actually
learned about yeah he's an Orange County
kid he's a 3d developed under under Leon
Rice at Boise State he's a really got
two really good players but I don't
think Carter's gonna be a star but he
could be but you got to get it's like
what Golden State did you got to get
really a bunch of really good players
and then lockout and the one becoming a
star Orlando star as a free agent yeah I
am and also with the Lakers with Mo
Vaughn er they see a guy who sticks on
this team yes they like most low vogner
a lot and he can shoot he's smart he's
he's not great at defending on the
perimeter but look I mean it's pretty
obvious whatever what the NBA is
trending towards you know either as a
big guy either you're a rim protector or
you got to be a floor stretcher and you
got to be able to cover on you know it's
a switch happy NBA you can't do that
then you can't play in this league which
which brings us back to the number one
pick which I like the Andre eight he's a
tremendous prospect but the best thing
he does is he's incredibly agile in the
low post right and that's that's the
part of the NBA that's being minimized I
mean you know I came on your guys show
last year and I will I will grovel and
give it up to the guys because I believe
who was it who had who said there's
gonna be a run on running backs in the
NFL Draft two years ago it wasn't Seton
was it wasn't it was McLovin and he's
right the problem is that drafting a
running back in the first round when you
can get one in the second or the third
round
same thing with Center you know like the
Robert Williams kid at am whoo-whoo-whoo
Boston got like I don't think he's great
but he could be a Clint capela type and
you can win big with that whereas it's
really hard to win big with a true low
post player
I know Aidan can face up and shoot the
basketball but that's the part of his
game that he has to develop the best
part of his games in a low post and not
really a rim protector defensively so it
goes against conventional wisdom but I
wouldn't have gone with a center number
one overall because the NBA is telling
you don't throw the ball low post we're
making it harder and harder to play
through the post so you would have taken
Bagley one yes because he can he's a
Chris Bosh type yes or even taking even
even pate taking a tonic one just you
know the coach coached him he coached
him in for a Euro championship you had a
great relationship
you put the best players out there on
the floor you play small ball you go I
would have considered it like look that
thing was done a long time ago the
owners in Arizona guy the kid played a
little high school and errors you know
play College in Arizona I mean like all
that and he was by many many people's
number one boards I'm just looking at it
and saying okay show me where the low
post play the low post Center exists
in the NBA playoffs if you're Phoenix
you're like look we've been so far from
the playoffs we can't even we can't even
figure that out the league is clearly
trending you know marcin Gortat can be
given away by the Wizards Dwight Howard
can't find a job and I know that Aidan's
a better face up shooter than then
either of those two and he's younger
he's agile he has no injury history but
look at the trend of the league and you
have to adjust to it because if you
don't you're gonna be left with
mismatched pieces and I mean that's kind
of what happened Oklahoma City that's
what happened to San Antonio in many
ways you're left with two post players
or even one post player and sometimes
your best player can't be on the floor
in key situations Doug have a great
weekend thanks for joining us as always
all right boys listen I know you guys
are off yeah in a week we'll hold the
fort down and we'll you feel free to
call in from vacation and parts unknown
and that's not just you Dan McLovin can
call in Seaton can call in even fritzy
College thank you Doug that's Doug
Godley who apparently is filling in for
us when we're on vacation and Doug just
invited me to call into my show while
I'm on vacation
thoughtful what part of vacation did
Doug not understand Doug oddly fox
sports college basketball analyst for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]